[Music]
so hi this is Caleb Envy I'm computing
again for Eric Hanson who perpetually
out today so today on a games you should
know by heart we're going a game from
the Baku open and Azerbaijan between
Alekseev and Irina crush save probably I
don't know I'm terrible with names but
ok so he opened with e4 against crushed
she was playing black crush play e5
Knight f3 d6 and Bishop b5 check so of
course um black can play this or this
either valuable moves I think we should
be sends the move as well I'm very
unfamiliar with Sicilians but ok so 97
was played on the d4 breaking the center
nice f6 and castles alright
so already white is sacrificing upon so
black accepts
um apparently a better line is to take
this pawn first and after Queen to d4
there are a few different options such
as a six or g6 or e5 going into a few
different sectors but instead crush snag
the pond right away sir 51 gaining time
on the night tonight back to f6
he takes e5 and D takes e5 so apparently
pressure already adds this position
before back in 1999 and there her
opponent played g5 and preserved her
extra pawn and shoot from Zurich
Director pawn and later won that game in
this case why it went straight to the
throat with Knight g5 so sort of taking
advantage of blacks black and
development with this bishops being
hemmed in and attacking some links pawns
on f7 and the later East 6 square if
black dares to play this move so black
played h6 sorry II 6
of course not h6 um another line would
be h6 which is probably why I set it at
those reading it and in this line white
immediately sacks on f7 that's right so
King takes f7 and Bishop c4 check sorry
TV e8 and this was actually played in
the deep blue Gary Kasparov match so
Bishop f4 so they would continue
followed by something like just 93 and
attacking the centralized king would be
standard so e6 instead so in your
development which Knight c3 and after
Bishop d7 black is basically threatening
to castle and have all those problems
resolved right just up upon for nothing
and should be as fine game forum for her
excuse me for Irina so white has to act
now
so how can white either sacrifice a
piece or prepare to sacrifice a piece in
order to rip open the position and
prevent castling it's also very
important to mention yeah of course it's
just Queen e2 so the point of the course
after castling Knight takes c6 on 66
maybe 6 or a kept 7 and Bishop c4 yeah
so black will lose the piece back on e7
if you try something like Queen f8 and
anything else would just lose the rook
immediately so black cannot castle after
Queen e2 and a6 display by arena oh
sorry
should overwrite
okay so now how should white continue
going straight for the throat yeah so
the simple it was played isn't it takes
uh seven ignoring the thread on the
bishop uh something like Bishop c4 is
really just wasting time because my fix
up seven works immediately and how could
the black try to break out here a good
question
yeah I was thinking something like ip6
could be playable with just opening the
bishops to help defend the king or the
e6 pawn and again preparing to castle so
yeah knight of seven here I don't think
it's quite as good maybe seem possible
maybe just your trading too many pieces
after Bishop e6 and King King f8 yeah
yeah Queen b6 might be coming and also I
think Queenie six is probably necessary
to survive and if you try something like
Bishop f4 maybe Knight to d5 ideas could
save the day yeah
anyway the pieces regardless are just
obstinately placed with the bishop on b5
keeping this Bishop out of the game and
pinning down this Knight
so the time to strike is definitely now
so night except 7 King 607 of course
Queen 66 King to f8 and now finally we
respond to the term of the bishop with
Bishop c4 with this very subtle threat
very subtle so yeah how does black
respond here Queenie 8 definitely forced
to and now we have to continue the
attack please
you
yeah that's right just getting more
pieces out getting this bishop with
ideas and fish tv6 and the game and
preparing to bring a second rook and if
need be
ah that's a similar idea to what
happened in the game but on Knight b6
unfortunately your nights hanging oh
yeah yeah that's what frosh tried to do
actually she's play Knight to be 8 to
get her Bishop out so now how do we
continue because you could just play
something like Queen de - but then
blacks going to like they'll develop his
pieces and start to be free Queen takes
f6 yeah not quite not quite it of course
be very nice to see G takes f6 with a
little little crisp and a little cross
but of course Bishop takes up sticks
when there's nothing better after yeah
just push up e7 here so there'd be
nothing better than north take the aid
when you're just out material
it's definitely I'd say the definition
of counterintuitive but you're on the
right track with Queen to f6 trying to
deflect some important pieces yeah yeah
but it's a necessary move
yeah Queens d6 that's right so exactly
so yeah definitely don't want to take
this queen is after Bishop takes Queen
d7 rook takes or Bishop takes actually I
think I like Bishop takes a bit better
after King it you just take this with
check and then King d7 you're just
coming in here with check and obviously
it's very very bad so this coin is off
limits
yeah so very nicely so as the peanut
gallery pointed out you need some more
defenders on e7 here so Knight takes
Knight to c6 rather is very important
completing the rear out of the Knights
and now how can white continue the
attack we again need to play with some
urgency or else black will develop the
pieces and be free yeah that's right
just breaking through so after Queen
takes e7 exactly so whoops
you hung checkmate except not quite
because of the pen so black heads quite
a tough time working out here
of course Queen takes d6 once again
tableau because of the same ethic where
you lose all your pieces
or even heretics here could be strong
actually this might just be checkmate
immediately
but regardless no good so crush
responded with Knight to e8 trying to
hang on by hitting the Queen in an
attempt to distract it from this attack
on the e7 square there's a couple things
you have to notice right first of all if
you do something slow this works going
to be hanging with mate so things like
Queen to d5 don't work trying to
threaten me oh yeah so that's actually
right Queen to be one of the move it's
better than Queen to d2 just because
your queen has a lot less options from
the square they really can't get out to
f4 and yeah yeah but hanging a rook sure
so going to be one aiming at the f3
squared and get the h5 squared both
those ideas of hitting up seven well
right now you're on the Queen so you're
going to have time to play these moves
so black played Queen to f6 trying to
defend making it attempt yeah putting in
the effort so now how can you I continue
yeah 95 so just bringing all pieces into
the attack gaining tempo on the quitting
time on the Queen and defending the
bishops ah plaque again move this Queen
to g6 this time and here there are a few
different winning moves the one played
in the game was the stellar night to see
seven attacking a one too many times and
of course if Knight takes t7 yeah Bishop
takes Bishop d6 check as well as Queen
d6 everything ones but yeah so here
black attempted Bishop to g4 defending
the knight once again but now the final
move of well not the final minutes I'm
sorry but here what can white do take
the rook
well not quite not quite black doesn't a
threat believe it or not flag did make
it through out with Bishop c4 rook e8
well that's why he played Bishop g4 or
she played Bishop g4 to defend the night
hmm
we're 68 well yeah that was the idea
behind Bishop g4 is now the thrift
defense so you don't have quite enough
to make this work efficiency six here on
ninety seven and we're defending just
enough I think and yeah you don't quite
have a ninety five because unfortunately
artists rollin chest well first of all
your Queen moves love yet first of all
your Quinn's hanging second of all Queen
through sideways but okay so yeah this
is the idea behind Bishop g4 to stop
birth to e8 stuff
so what idea has been like weeding to
mate this whole time right it's been
Queen to d6 so how can you use this
diagonal effectively
yeah that's right so Queenie d5 so now
switching focus from the d6 squared of
the c5 squared as well as obviously
threatening things on f7 things such as
check and also mates so rook to d8 was
played stepping out of the Knights
attack and Queen takes e5 so black
responded and that could be six
obviously media's take that night
we're tasty six and now the final move
of the game well the second two lemons
yeah just just captured just capture the
rook and this will be the end right yeah
that was a pretty insane apparently yeah
this game was just under out and I was
actually 25 I thought it was just under
30 but it was 25 minutes exactly
this is best attacking games of 2012 to
2015 by an iTouch and below
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]